[Music]
on this Wednesday night liberated but
still in the crosshairs the Ukrainian
city of hersan still under Relentless
attack Global's Jeff Semple takes us
there this is a baby's room what's been
lost and where people find Hope system
failure Why women's symptoms of heart
disease and stroke are often overlooked
celebrating the life of Tyree Nichols
for this to happen to him it's just
unimaginable the demands for justice and
political action
plus Mission Impossible accomplished how
a tiny radioactive capsule was tracked
down in a vast Australian Outback
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight in Ukraine where a
Relentless Russian offensive is gaining
momentum in the East Russian forces
claim they have captured a village near
back moot a key City Russia is trying to
surround here's the situation on the
ground Russian troops are regrouping and
gradually advancing the goal is to
capture the entire Eastern region that
strategy includes the southern city of
hersan it was the only Regional Capital
to be captured by the Russians Following
last year's Invasion Ukrainian forces
managed to retake it in November but the
city is still in the crosshairs since
the Russians left her son has been fired
on more than 1700 times at least 74
people have been killed including one
child our Jeff Semple along with
videographer Darren twiss just returned
from the city in our top story tonight
they give us an inside look at Ukrainian
life near the front line
at this Ukraine maternity hospital they
used to escape the Russian rockets by
Sheltering in the basement but last
month it took a direct hit
video of the immediate aftermath shows
charred baby cribs thankfully no one was
down here
the power of the explosion shattered
windows on the upper floors turning
shards of glass into projectiles so
that's the window that was broken and
this is a baby's room
the blast broke every window in this
neonatal unit except for one in the room
where a newborn baby was sleeping
that's her Polina Malika
the window above her crib was the only
one that didn't get blown up paulina's
mother says it was just a miracle after
eight months under Russian occupation
the city of her son was liberated in
November the Russians retreating just
across the river sparking celebrations
in the streets
that Euphoria was short-lived
and you can hear the steady drum beat of
artillery here behind me this city has
been under constant shelling with dozens
of hits almost every single day the
Russians came here last year claiming to
be liberating the city but now that they
have been forced out of here it seems
their intent on destroying it
the shelling continues all day and all
night it's very scary this resident told
us Moscow claims it's targeting military
and energy infrastructure but during our
visit Russian Rockets slammed into
apartment buildings and crashed through
the roof of this house we found the
homeowner in shock smoking a pipe on his
porch this is just a residential street
this is people's homes here right yeah
not a military
no no I'm not certain military
the whole of her son is within range
there's no safe place said this military
spokesperson
the Russians don't care what they're
firing at the targets have included
churches and schools this bomb shelter
next to a grocery store has its door
propped open by shrapnel from a rocket
that struck here on Christmas eve even
the Children's Hospital has been hit
three times
one boy was injured twice by shelling
once on the street and then again in
hospital when his window shattered the
hospital director says the Russians
lived here for eight months they know
where this hospital is located they're
trying to destroy us no sooner had she
spoken than another mortar landed not
far away
prompting her to grab her helmet and
body armor which she now keeps beside
her desk
her son's main Square the site of
November's celebrations now sits mostly
empty but for a small crowd lining up
for donations of food the vast majority
of her son's 300 000 residents have fled
many Who Remain are frail and sick
unable to leave
Tatiana and her husband Stefan are
marking their 60th wedding anniversary
while living in their Cellar after their
home was flattened is there anywhere
else they can go
we're freezing here through the winter
she says we're living worse than pigs
maybe paulina's mother tells us they're
all so reluctant to leave the city her
father was taken prisoner by the
Russians during the occupation they
haven't seen him in six months
we are waiting hoping he will return
soon so he can hold the hand of his
granddaughter she says oh you can take
through it all Paulina sleeps soundly
even his artillery Thunders outside
their apartment
her future now bound to the outcome of a
war she was born into
I'm an optimist her mother says I still
believe that soon this horror will stop
and our city will be able to provide a
future for our kids
a few days after our visit to the
maternity hospital where Paulina was
born the building was hit again this
time entire hospital rooms were
destroyed three more civilians were
killed just this week
her son has been liberated but the cost
of its freedom is growing by the hour
Jeff Semple Global News her son
back here in Canada even finding a
family doctor is impossible for
thousands of people and now there's new
data specifically about women's health a
study by the Heart and Stroke Foundation
identifies alarming gaps in diagnosing
caring and even basic understanding of
risk factors and symptoms of heart
attacks and strokes in women you data
shows more than 32 thousand Canadian
women died of heart disease and stroke
in 2019 that is one woman every 16
minutes women who have a stroke are at a
higher risk of dying than men and if
they survive their outcomes are worse
Catherine Ward reports on why there's
been so little progress in changing that
I did present to emerge a lot because I
was having heart attack symptoms like
daily
a runner
a teacher
a mother to young children for years
Bobby Joe Greene could not figure out
why she was feeling so sick and neither
could the eight cardiologists she saw
over five years it was just kind of a
revolving door of Specialists ER
Physicians GPS telling me it's not your
heart reassuring me it can't be your
heart right you're too young you're too
fit you're too healthy not being
believed was just as bad and just as
traumatic as having the illness green
kept pushing for a diagnosis and
eventually learned her heart was not
getting enough oxygen and the arteries
and vessels were not functioning
properly her story is not uncommon
according to a new report from the Heart
and Stroke Foundation the numbers
indicate symptoms go unrecognized for 50
percent of women experiencing a heart
attack in part this is because men and
women present differently as a result
women are less likely than men to
receive the treatments or medications
they need and women are more likely than
men to have died in the year following a
heart attack the bottom line heart
attacks and Strokes are the leading
cause for premature death for women in
Canada
some risk factors for women include
pregnancy and menopause smoking high
blood pressure diabetes obesity and
depression are also on the list doctors
say more gender-based research is needed
to fully understand the scope of the
issue women traditionally have not been
involved in research as much and because
of that we don't have as much data on
their heart health if we don't take care
of the risk factors that it could
continue to rise and not only will be
the number one premature cause of death
but will be a real leading sort of
worldwide issue in women Catherine Ward
Global News Toronto
some high-powered testimony in Ottawa
today Canada's former ambassador to
China and former head of the
international consulting firm McKenzie
has appeared before a committee after it
came to light McKenzie has received
multiple Federal contracts worth more
than 100 million dollars Dominic Barton
said today that contrary to Media
reports he is not a close friend to
prime minister Justin Trudeau and has
never been alone in a room with him
David Aiken our chief political
correspondent is watching the testimony
David yeah a lot of political theater
here Donna Dominic Barton spent two
hours in front of a has a Commons
committee this afternoon and not
surprisingly the opposition was looking
to score some political points we know
McKenzie strengths that they're able to
swing sole source contracts and get
money out of Canadians that their
weaknesses that are scandal after
Scandal Barton says any work that his
old firm McKenzie did for the government
of Canada was one fair and square Mr
Barton would you consider yourself a
close personal friend of the Prime
Minister no I'm not a close personal
friend of the Prime Minister would you
say he's one of your five best friends
no one of your 10 best friends no one of
your 25 best friends no one of your 50
best friends no
do you have his personal phone number I
do not do you and the Prime Minister
exchange birthday cards every year
birthday presents no do you and your
wife go out to dinner with the Prime
Minister and his wife no
now that may be fair enough but there is
no question that mckinsey's federal
government business flourished when the
Trudeau government came to office here's
the stats during the Harper government's
nine years in office McKinsey and
Company won just six contracts with a
combined 3.3 million dollars but in the
seven years since Justin Trudeau has
taken over McKinsey has received 28
contracts worth a combined 107 million
dollars the high-priced Consultants are
making off like Bandits and one of the
biggest winners Justin Trudeau's friends
over at McKenzie his personal friend
Dominic Barton the former director of
McKenzie I had no involvement whatsoever
in any awarding of paid work to McKinsey
by the federal government since I
relocated to Asia in 1996
David how politically vulnerable might
the Trudeau government be over this
heavy Reliance on outside Consultants
yeah that's a good question because the
big knock on the Trudeau government has
always been that it's all about a lot of
talk and not necessarily about a lot of
action indeed we did an analysis of all
government contracts issued back to 2006
and what it shows is that while the
Harper government spent about 27 billion
dollars on Consultants the Trudeau
government has already spent 41 billion
dollars on consultants and that's not
just McKinsey that's all of them
Deloitte Accenture the whole bunch now
have these Consultants help reduce
Hospital wait times have they cut the
cost of living have they made it easier
to get a passport all these issues well
voters at the next election might want
an incumbent government to point at more
accomplishments rather than point to a
neatly designed policy process that some
consultant came up with Donna all right
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you
to our CMP officers have been charged
with manslaughter after the death of an
indigenous man in Prince George BC three
other officers are charged with
obstructing justice 35-year-old Dale
Culver died in July 2017 the independent
investigations office of BC said RCMP
were called after reports of a man
casing Vehicles Culver was pepper
sprayed and placed in the back of a
police cruiser he had trouble breathing
and collapsed when an ambulance arrived
in 2018 the BC civil liberties
Association filed a complaint with a
civilian review and complaints
commission for the RCMP alleging
mounties had told witnesses to delete
video footage of Culver's arrest
now to Tennessee in the funeral for a 29
year old man who died after being
brutally beaten by Memphis police
officers Tyree Nichols was pulled over
in a routine traffic stop his tearful
mother said today no other child should
suffer the way her son did and she
called for Action Jackson prosco reports
as Tyree Nichols was laid to rest in
Memphis he was honored by a family and a
community left devastated by his death
when those
monsters
murder my baby brother
they left me completely heartbroken the
29 year old was remembered as a father a
Man Who Loved a skateboard and a son
taken far too soon Tyree was a beautiful
person
and for this to happen to him it's just
unimaginable
this celebration of life was a clear
call to action a call to end the
long-standing Injustice and inequality
too often faced by black Americans at
the hands of police we have come with
heavy hearts
that can only be healed by the grace of
God
full transparency
accountability
and comprehensive legislative reform
Tyree Nichols had committed no crime
when he was pulled over by Memphis
Police he was beaten to death by five
black officers all of them since charged
with murder you beat a brother to death
there's nothing more inside team
an offensive it's a tragedy too familiar
for too many families in the crowd of
mourners were the relatives of other
victims of police brutality George Floyd
Eric Garner Brianna Taylor joined by
vice president Kamala Harris who is
pushing federal police reform
legislation this is a family that lost
their son and their brother
through an act of violence there is both
a fear that Tyree Nichols will not be
the last victim and a sense that his
death has shown rapid accountability is
possible with charges coming so quickly
his story has shown anger and sorrow in
a nation where equality remains Out Of
Reach for too many
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
without police body cam video the
officers who beat Tyree Nichols may not
have been charged with murder coming up
a look at the advantages and the limits
of the technology
police body cameras are widely used in
the United States in many cases they've
lifted the curtain on police brutality
in the case of Tyree Nichols the fact
the officers were wearing them did not
stop them from using excessive force as
turia Israeli reports body cams aren't
as widely used in Canada
body cameras offer a window into a world
we don't often see
interactions between the public and
police
the new and family Wishes the Edmonton
officer who shot and killed their
brother was wearing one we would have
evidence of what happened we would have
Steven side of things since he's no
longer here we have no idea police were
responding to a call about a man with a
knife in June 2021. according to court
documents they never found a weapon only
a cell phone Edmonton does not plan on
equipping officers with body cams but
it's the exception most other major
Canadian cities are rolling them out
Toronto police nearby peel Montreal
Ottawa Calgary and Vancouver have
started using body cams or are
considering them the RCMP is also
bringing in body cams as many as 15 000
will be deployed Nationwide over the
next year and a half starting in Alberta
Nunavut and Nova Scotia but while most
police services are moving in this
direction criminologists say the
regulations haven't caught up it is a
patchwork and it's kind of fragmented
across across Canada instead of a
patchwork there's a push for national
standards the biggest problem I always
see with body cameras especially my
research is that where there's no way
that we can truly measure accountability
or transparency the Canadian Police
Association supports expanding the use
and believes strong guidelines are in
place but criminologists question the
effectiveness of body cams if an officer
is wearing a camera and it's recording
they're of course not going to engage in
any kind of police misconduct or
brutality again that's the belief you
know with the Nichols footage we see
clearly that's not the case Alam Babino
spent nearly 30 years with the RCMP and
now fights racial profiling in Quebec
it's Malton faceted it starts from uh
who do you attract uh as as police
officers who do you screened in or
screened out and how do you train them
while the technology has its limitations
Melissa Solano believes it's necessary I
think that every police in Canada should
have a body count a powerful tool
becoming increasingly prevalent tariya
isri Global News Ottawa
worker walkouts ahead why Britain was
hit with the biggest strike in a decade
[Music]
up to half a million workers in Britain
walked off the job today the largest
coordinated strike action in a decade
teachers civil servants and train
drivers were among those who took to the
streets their demanding pay increases
the UK government has taken a hard line
against workers saying giving in would
worsen the cost of living crisis
inflation in Britain is running at more
than 10 percent the highest in four
decades the FBI have searched a beach
house belonging to U.S President Joe
Biden as part of an investigation into
the handling of classified documents
they say no classified material was
found during what's described as a
planned search of Biden's vacation home
by classified documents from his time as
vice president were found at his
Wilmington home and at the Penn Biden
Center in Washington
lost and then found next Australia's
hunt to find a radioactive capsule
[Music]
there is relief in Australia after
what's described as a dangerous needle
in a haystack was found search Crews
have recovered a radioactive capsule
it's smaller than a dime and it fell off
a mining truck traveling through the
Outback Eric Sorensen explains why they
work so hard to find it
it's hard to say which was more
astonishing losing it or finding it a
truck rumbling over the Australian
Outback apparently shook loose the bolts
of a container and a tiny radioactive
capsule just fell out it took days to
notice then the painstaking search
nuclear experts programming roadside
scanning with radiation detecting
equipment we haven't found it but the
search continues the capsule is used for
detecting density and iron ore it was
being transported in Western Australia
from Rio tinto's mine near Newman to a
storage facility at Perth but that's
like from Vancouver to Saskatoon
searching some 1400 kilometers of
Highway for one little pellet good luck
newscasters sounded bewildered the tiny
radioactive Capsule that's missing
somewhere in Western Australia the
concern that someone would find it and
not realize the danger if somebody worse
or discovered somewhere along the Route
we are very keen that they do not handle
it the capsule wasn't highly radioactive
then again again
it's not the kind of thing you play
around with an eight millimeter long
cylinder the diameter is smaller than a
dime it contains radioactive cesium-137
and if a human were to be around it for
just one hour it would be like absorbing
10 x-rays it could cause skin burns or
radiation sickness but after six days
the hunt hit pay dirt and there it was
detectors had picked up the signal a
couple of meters off the highway it is
great news that we have found that
source and it's such a rapid period of
time it was strange to lose track of it
and just as crazy to relocate it though
there's no Foundation to the fears that
in Australia radioactivity could create
giant mice put entire species to sleep
or make people speak differently
from Australia it's all natural fun for
me
still an investigation will take place
we're sorry that that has occurred the
head of the mining company apologized
but also looked on the bright side when
you think about a pretty incredible uh
recovery when you think of the distances
involved everyone was amazed the search
groups have quite literally found the
needle in the haystack and contained any
Fallout in the outback Eric Sorensen
Global News
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the Cowichan Valley near
Duncan British Columbia we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
thank you
[Music]